yes Frank is one of the most
intimidating characters you must
intimidate people in real life just
because they associate you with the
character I always try to tell people
remember this guy look how nice he is
yeah you know I was on a plane not very
long ago maybe about a year ago and I
just was reading a script and you know
how we go back and forth from coast to
coast and I would travel everywhere with
him exactly my right-hand man right here
and I get up to go to the bathroom and
there's a lady waiting in line for the
bathroom and she looks over her shoulder
and she just stops and freezes and she
turns around slowly again and she looks
at me and she sees me and she says you
you can go yeah and I said no no you're
in line for the bathroom just go ahead
go to the bathroom and she's no no cake
Gus you go and she would not move off
the wall she is ping right to the wall
so I go to the bathroom I come back out
I say hey my name is Giancarlo I'm not
gosh she says I know but you just go
back to my seat now have a good piss
that's what I think to say to a woman
have a good piss
you